video game culture needs to stop
fetishizing skill crybabies the physical
glass ceiling when they get good
mentality turns ablest have you played I
want to be the guy have you played it
have you played it if so did you make it
pass the first screen my name is
PewDiePie I'm on a mission to beat this
game based on my wonderful comments that
are supporting me on this journey
here we go I've only died three three
three times oh my god that's half the
devil times I don't even remember how to
play oh my god
oh my god we're here
[Music]
fine it can't be that bad great
actually nevermind I forgot about that
one
all right I know how to make it there oh
there's a bird there's a bird what do I
do
stop stop stop you goddamn bird stop
stop stop [ __ ] pace Magazine and polygon
they were right games journalism was
right I don't understand there's so many
steps I have to jump this one gotta
watch out for them and then the Apple
and then the third edit it's like oh my
god okay look at this perfect for it I'm
gonna do it I'm gonna do this on the
first try first try baby come on zero
deaths and then you walk back and then
forward them first try okay you do the
jump then you walk back and then forward
in the back lets you do the first jump
you do the first jump you gotta wait for
the timing you gotta wait for the timing
do that right and then you gotta walk
back then forward them back if you got
to do the first jump you got to do the
first jump you got to do the first jump
wait for the timing you go in back and
back and forth and you got to do the
first jump right
[Music]
first jump oh I get an oh okay I see
first right
okay so first gem stand there and then
you go back I got it
look at that how easy that is once you
know how to do it and I didn't even
watch a Mexican jacquard damn it so you
gotta jump up here what's up with bird
and then all the apples all the apples
okay and they're zombies at the same
time at the same time you got it at the
same time come on comma easy easy now
now more birds that's fine that's fine
there's birds everywhere in life you
just gotta deal with it
alright okay here it comes here it comes
come on here we go come on
get hyped get high come on come on come
on come on come on come on come on come
on come on I don't know I don't
understand this jump I just don't
understand it you have to understand the
jump to make the jump you can't just
jump you have to know the jump you have
to breathe the jump you have to be the
cat come on wait for the right moment
Felix wait for the right moment your
time and will arise the young child
young child your time will come
oh now no now run fun look at this
perfect skills jump
alright look at this goddamn perfect
skills we do the look at this guy damn
perfect skills we'll do the first gym we
go here when wait for the dangle with
Jim perfect a me now we watch out for
the club and now we prepare herself for
the bird we shoot the prayer first apple
not a problem
shoot the Sam B's shoot the zambese
watch out for apples keep shooting
Sammy's more applause the more zombies
what are you gonna do Sam [ __ ] mother 1
another one oh it's good oh he
celebrates but never he's got a shield
all the parts it's gotta shoot all the
purse he waits patiently for his right
time just kidding
he goes for it he goes through all of it
oh he does it perfectly but he only has
one chance to blow he Christ like a
little baby no oh this is not good
[Music]
yes yes
what now what now what are you gonna do
you know that shit's not gonna let me go
there come on I'm gonna count down from
five five four three two it's a it's a
it's a it's a bird I can say it it's
gonna be a bird
one are you [ __ ] stupid what was that
I didn't even jump in
I didn't even jump looks like we have to
do all this again
[Music]
took a little break watch me watch me do
this on the first try
watch me do it on first try first try
watch me do it watch me do it on first
try first try watch me do it first try
first try first try watch me do it come
on
first track first run first string first
fret first RAM of the trucker's bird
first fry first ride is easy easy first
trap Fritz try come on come on
[Music]
[ __ ] that doesn't even make any sense
why did he move why did it go down first
try come up from
first era daddy
sure dad Sarah - Sarah Sarah - Sarah how
many deaths sera sera sera sera sera
wherever you be you be Sarah Sarah Sarah
- sera sera sera - someone the bar
[Music]
back but I went back I can do this I'm
Felix mother flipping Shelburne
Christian Channel and respect famine and
dead memes thank you thank you very much
come on you [ __ ] pakka makka come on
come on come on dude come on come on
come on get high get come on come on
come on oh oh
that was some terrible timing yes yes
[ __ ] my Swedish yeah you're gonna make
this Felix you're gonna make this you're
gonna make this minute you're gonna make
this go
[Music]
yes oh okay oh yeah here he's pleased
come on I'm so this took me 15 minutes
it took me 15 minutes to get back here
15 minutes are you kidding are you
kidding
[Music]
yes yes yes yes goodbye
leave a like bra